[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round one of the
Spring Classic here in st. Louis two
decisive results in group a grandmaster
Jeffrey Zhang defeated grandmaster euros
euro book with black + 2006 US champ
grandmaster Alex onna shook put away
grandmaster Alex EBU table with white
group B saw only one decisive gate as
grandmaster action Chandra bested
grandmaster Andrei Corvettes with white
Chandra is off to a good start as he
looks for redemption in his City this
early anything can happen
coverage of round 2 starts now with over
$30,000 in pride on the line 20
international chess professionals
converged in st. Louis for the 2018
spring chess Classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the second annual 2018 spring
chess classic then this is round two we
are in the midst of it the players have
started several hours ago and we're here
for the next 90 minutes or so to tell
you all about the happenings and give
you some analysis I'm Ben Simon and I'm
international master of Italian a murmur
and already two games have ended today
and like you saw in the intro Group B
yesterday that was all Akshat Chandra
the only victory thus far in the round
and then two decisive games in the top
section as well vitaly what are your
thoughts so far in this tournament yeah
I think that today we're in a pretty
good start
we saw some decisive games but think I
still think that the players are still
treading the water just trying to see
that the comfort that was the first day
there probably were tile and traveling
so yeah today I'm gonna see some
exciting fights it might be about to
pick up let's take a look at last
night's results the round did not end
until about 6 o'clock right as we were
going off the air these are the results
from the top group yeah we had a game s
of original Cobian a drawing with white
pieces against any Italian spirits again
mess of same Shanklin it drew against
the end Messer Lazaro zone again master
Roman remain Edward drew against young
master Surya Ganguly and that as we said
we had to decisive results again master
Alex only shook and one with white
against Kane master Alex epitope and
gain master Jeffrey Zhang one with the
black pieces against the arrow available
and let's put it into perspective for
you and take a look at the standings
after just one round so we have
grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang and Alexander
on the shook of both leading with one
point so far and from place for the
third place
until the 8th place we have Lazaro zone
same Shanklin those words
Surya Ganguly evolution of Kobe on the
romaine Edward with a half a point
the bottom of the list was have
Aleksandra epitope and the Ariston
shareable and the stories of this
tournament may turn out to be the young
Geoffrey Zhang and the veteran Alex onus
shook to competitors who will be in the
US Championship this year which starts
next month momentum from round to round
is a real thing is momentum from month
to month a real thing vitally oh I
believe so I mean I think that if you if
you are feeling in shape and yes
definitely is you know you have your
feeling that that's coming over that the
twin streak yeah I think so well let's
see
and now the challengers section or Group
B the round last night surprised us a
little bit at the end and I promise
you're right as we went off the air we
had an unexpected well it became kind of
expected result in grab in skis game
with a wonder Leon yeah definitely so we
had we have seen a few draws in that
round Alexandra field drew against JJ
Alomar on D priyadarshan come upon drew
against Victor McAuliffe ski and Malika
Cheon drew against jack Steinberg and as
we said Erin grab it ski drew against
the Wando Liang the only decisive game
was action Chandra beating with white
again master Andre governments I made a
point of saying that Griffin ski and a
Wonder surprised us because it did look
like crap in ski had the upset for quite
a bit and then it petered out into an
unwinnable position right yeah so he was
basically a piece up and then I I guess
is his King got stuck on 81 and there
was no way to to win that that end game
but still I think that Erin grabbed in
ski as the the lowest rated player in
that field made a draw against the
highest rated I want to the end that's a
pretty good result for the first round
the highest rated and the defending
Group B Spring Classic champion from
last year now if we take a look at the
overall standings for the beat group we
can see that it's a little lonely at the
top but not by much Oxshott Chandra st.
Louis's own the guy lives right down the
street
he's as st. Louis as any import can get
what a great guy one point leading the
field right now but it's also very early
okay so if we bring it back we are all
caught up to what is happening right now
in the tournament but we have games that
are being played live right now they
started a few hours ago we do have two
results in let's take a look at the
pairings that are going on right now in
our masters group yeah so in a group a
we have various words playing against
Jeffrey Zhang Alex epitope is playing
against yeah Roger go Surya Ganguly is
playing as Alex only shook the zebra
zone is playing against remain Edward
and the version of children is facing
same Shanklin and I think the game of
the day to watch here should be
Grandmaster Ganguly of India versus
ownership of the u.s. ownership
yesterday got a win over Alex EBIT of
the Battle of the Alex's and so that
should be the game to watch in my
opinion but there are several here does
anything stand out to you let's see I
think there's going to be an interesting
fight to see Alex epital playing and
Sierra's Arabic because they're both
lost yesterday but I think we actually
already have a result before that but
other than that and everything was
pretty open to me right now we thought
it might be interesting I want to talk
about that in just a few minutes here
but that game is indeed over epi' top
injure book have drawn and Akopian and
Shanklin have drawn but just so we get
all cued up here in the right spot let's
take a look at the pairings in the B
group that are going on right now and
you can catch all this at us chess
champs calm here they are all these
games are still active yeah we have
undergarments playing against Jake stay
block victim McAuliffe skis playing as
Malik catchy on jayjay Morandi is
playing against player - icon upon the
one delaying is facing Alexander fear
and action Chandler is facing Erin grab
in ski and we have some dynamic game so
far glancing at some quick analysis
here on my own computer we'll be sure to
look at it but I think the game of the
day here in my opinion is a shot Chandra
versus Aaron Grubb in ski let's see I
want to see if Aaron group in ski can
keep performing at higher than you know
supposedly he's expected to that'll be
interesting
actually I Chandra of course at this
game you talk about momentum this is the
one I'm looking at right now oh yeah
definitely I just I was looking at the
game live at the tomb that whole week
shame you guys are here come come to
stop by I saw that Aaron Kaminsky's was
blitzing out his move so I think he came
prepared indeed
alright and this tournament is pretty
simple to understand the tournament
format is 210 player round robins 10 in
each field the time control each player
gets 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
and once they make that time control
they get a bonus 30 minutes added on to
their clock and then that is for the
remainder of the game no more bonus time
there all the players will receive a 30
second increment from move number one
and remember in this tournament there
are no playoffs so hopefully we have a
clear winner but if we don't they'll be
sharing the prize as co-champions here's
the schedule for the spring chess
classic everyday the round start at us
chess champs calm and here in at the st.
Louis chess club at 1:00 p.m. Central
however the last two rounds March 13th
and March 14th things will be getting
underway at 11:00 a.m. this is not due
to playoffs this is actually due to
protest League commitments the internet
chess league so though that's why we're
starting early those last two days we
are on the air every day two and a half
hours after the round begins so 3:30 for
us everyday
central and then 1:30 for the last two
rounds and to throw a little wrench into
our plans
daylight savings time on Sunday right if
we so will be switching it up an hour
but will remind you don't worry and I'm
sure all the clocks are digital now so
they'll switch on their own we won't
lose anything these players are playing
for
a lot of prize money here golly that
something I want to take a look at the
prize money in the top field twenty-two
thousand dollar prize but look at how
that breaks down yeah we have the first
place is going to go home with six
thousand dollars second and third place
they are going to take four thousand and
three thousand dollars and everything
else just breaks down two thousand
fifteen hundred and one thousand dollars
even for the last place not too bad but
pretty impressive indeed and the big
group has its own prize fund a combined
fourteen thousand dollars up for grabs
here look at that not too bad
yeah the first place is going to take
four thousand dollars and then twenty
five hundred for second place don't base
is two thousand and then we have fifteen
hundred want to be in one thousand and
five hundred for last place
lovely yeah vitaliy it's time to look at
the games alright what piques your
interest first
alright them actually let's see that
lets see the game since got drunk first
so which one got drawn the first first
one was epic table and share a book and
and they drew you may notice if you're
following along on the chest 24 module
on us chest champs that the players drew
right after move 30 and we do have a 30
move rule in effect and what that means
is the players cannot offer and agree to
draw as before 30 moves and that's
supposed to encourage fighting chess you
know less lazy draws less grandmaster
draws as they say and it works most of
the time what do you make of this
drawing so early battalion well I think
that both of the players they they lost
yesterday so there might be a bit upset
or they might be out of the preparation
so just to keep it on the safe side
maybe their kids for a droplet booty
early but yes just to mention that
though the move roll will want people we
like to get some fighting spirit over
here in st. Louis so that's why we have
this swirl typically most tournaments
here do have the 30 move rule
occasionally there are those where you
don't see and I mean at that point
players can agree to a draw it you know
in theory at seven moves you know so
this is we're gonna see a game being
played even if it's gonna end quickly
but yeah let's how did this happen here
all right well let's see so the game
stopped up in a pretty famous opening we
have the Queens gambit declined and a
knight CT a very popular a structure for
for white and black basically white is
going to develop or both of these
Knights then Bishop g5 h6 Bishop h4
castle III I'm sure that the guys just
blitzed out those moves then we have a
bishop exchange over here rook the rook
c1 if I'm mistaken this is called the
Luster's variation and now Bishop d3 so
basically they exchange all the pieces I
think White's going to Castle taking on
c4 or so and at this point white gets
the advantage of those two central pawns
on d4 and III so obviously white is a
bit better in this kind of positions but
let's see the question is can we make it
to a point so Bishop d3 was played c5
and that the idea for black is to
fianchetto his Bishop Bishop went to b7
take take
rook to serve on a nice triple of the
rooks and the Queen on the on the C file
the reason much to do going under the C
file so if I was played a tree then the
players made some developing moves rook
e8 h3e 590 85 we are pretty equal
position so far why is trying to push
did try to push for this pawn to before
to get this knife back Knight to d7 Rock
c7 okay so you here as we know in chess
looks a very strong one on the seventh
rank that's what Alexander
PIPA table is doing quintics on c7 and
now Knight to f6 hmm
sacrifice it upon on v6 okay so so far
it looks like black as a pawn up so
let's see what happened then Knight to
d5 and apparently here
the night is forking the Queen and the
pawn going to be five Knight takes on
before so again we on the material
equality over here and look to be one
just attacking the knight on own before
I wonder if there are any other options
for white to play here I wonder if I can
take here on this this pawn on d5 and if
the Queen takes maybe I can take on
before hmm
so that that might might have been an
option for white I cannot see any other
moves for for black
it seems really curious to me yeah so I
like instead white plays rook to be won
and at this point then the night I went
to see - well maybe White's idea was
somehow to trap tonight if you can see
at this moment the knight can only move
back to a3 so maybe that was their
decision then that Alex epitope made on
on the chessboard
do I take on e5 and try to win this this
endgame and yeah and by the way if we
exchange the Queen's for points against
the pawns it's probably going to be
ending in a draw
even though White has a pawn up you know
lots of the rook end games end of the
drill even with upon the up so in the
game he tried to restrict the night with
Ruby 192 and the Roxy one night 8:30 was
played Queen to c5 yeah that's
definitely a draw for after white has
played this move Queen to c5 a little
bit surprising to be honest I think that
white can still play on
for some kind of an advantage here maybe
moving the Queen to a 5 or a 4 I still
don't know how how white is going to
bring how black is going to bring his
knight back and I'm just attacking the
knight and I want to I want to play
something like rook c3 and attack and
just to take this night they are very
curious why did why played Queen c3 but
no so so basically after the Queen
exchange that's pretty much move number
31 and I get to draw called it to the
rolls
let's go taking that you know taking the
a purse out there yeah that's maybe
maybe prepare for the next for the next
game yeah it's a you know a half 1/2
point by with a little bit of play over
the board you know I know some people
might get mad at me for saying something
like that but really I mean if you're if
you're if you're feeling down after the
first day you know both players coming
off losses here you got to do what you
got to do
yeah yeah that's that's true and vitaliy
I'm looking at what I perceive is the
game of the day in Group A and if this
is a funny looking game I'm talking
about grandmasters Ganguly and Oda shook
its move 29 real time and all of the
pawns are still on the board this looks
kind of funny to me
yeah it looks really interesting
especially with the pawn structure you
know you wonder how did the pawn got to
e5 yeah it's probably because black
probably it captured with on f6 and then
captured on e6 twice and that that will
be my bet
I guess it's it's harder to decide whose
pawn structure is better it looks at
first that White's pawn structure is a
bit better because we here we have just
one point chain and that's what's
something we discussed yesterday black
does have this pawn on h6 which is kind
of an asset at at pawn but it's not
really a weakness like now the question
is I mean look at all those pawns in the
center
I mean maybe one day black is going to
start pushing those those ponds and
we'll see what happens as far as I can
see now it's a pretty equal the position
itself probably going to be some
exchanges I think that black eventually
will have to take this pawn on e5 and
try to try to put his knight on e5 so
right now it's white to move interesting
so maybe white can push I mean here so
many pawn moves here he can try to play
b 5 c 5 d 5 maybe even taking taking on
a5 i think i think it's a pretty
interesting game but my bet will be that
it would probably end in a draw let's
see what what kind of an opening they
played so it started with E 4 E 5 and we
have the go Akopian piano actually this
is the going of pianissimo this
variation is considered very fashionable
fashionable nowadays it used to be after
a 45 degree Lopez there used to be the
most fashionable one but today the top
chess players they prefer to put the
bishop on c7 on c4 excuse me
so let's see C 3 d6 a 4 that is a move
with a venom so why do we move the pawn
to a4 in the opening so early that does
not make any much of a sense but here's
the thing if black just going to cancel
here now
we can play d4 and it's almost time to
design for black yeah that bishops a
goner Bishop d6 and a5 so that's pretty
much the idea so after a full black
needed to defend and some people like to
play a six some people like to play the
spot for move pawn to a5 it's it's a
matter of preference depending on on
your style
hmm so Alex one issue decided to play
pawn to a6 Castle and Bishop to e7 a
very nice prophylactic move just in case
if white plays before one day I mean the
bishop is going to go to a7 anyway so
roof to e1 Castle h3 Bishop e6 a quick
development of the pieces yeah so now
why took on e6 he could also probably
play something like Knight bitty 2 is a
little bit more popular in those stages
and then if they're if the bishop takes
on c4 I can probably take with the
knight on c4 and so with the equal
position playable for both sides so on
the other hand Bishop took on e6 and
pawn takes only six now for our viewer's
today just to let you know it looks like
black has those double pawns on e6 and E
5 which we might think might be bad very
bad pawns but on the other hand at this
pawn on e6 it will be supporting the
advance of the d5 pawn so not right now
because the e5 phone will be weak but at
some point black has some ideas to push
d5 and white in if white takes on d5 we
can bring our epon and in addition black
gets the F file so if you can see that I
really like the dynamics of black pieces
actually because the rock on f8 and the
bishop on a7 just looking on this pawn a
5-2
and he's not not too far so we just need
to move those two nights so let's see
what happens so Bishop III this move
make sense as we said that Bishop on a7
is pretty dangerous sometimes Bishop
takes and he'll tally sorry to interrupt
yes Group B and Drake orbits has
defeated Jack shouldn't bully act so
we'll be talking to Andre corbett's here
in just a few moments just waiting to
step in and let you know alright perfect
yes mm and now that this our first
decisive results for the day yes indeed
the first one yeah and the only result
thus far in Group B how many more did
they make that's a good question
27 moves you see that's another yes/no
draws you are allowed to defeat your
opponent inside of 30 yeah good for them
yeah good for Andre yeah so as you can
see so this this in this game why I
decided to take with the rook not with
the pawn just a different approach Queen
d7 then we have a few night maneuvers
Knight to c4 rook a e8 basically wide
got a little more space but black has
some chances on the King side neither
for was a very nice output for the
Knights looking over the g2 upon the HT
pawn and d3 brought to d2 going to g2
3691 I I can I can feel the pressure
that that made that white might head
here in the position 97 but luckily
Europe to G coming to g3 and defending
the King 2793
there are few moves in
we have a few exchanges the Queen we got
Queen exchanges are hot and this is how
we got this pawn structure yeah it's
very interesting because black can take
on that six with the with the work if
you want to do but he decided to take
with a pawn
I wonder what which same shape I would
say about this about this disposal
structure right yeah we haven't seen the
book yet yeah we've seen the book we
haven't read the book so d4 was played
Knight back to g6 it looks to me like it
so far back just laid this move King to
f7 we have a sewer with twenty minutes
and Alexander with sixteen so it's no
it's it's very equal on time I equal on
the material and balanced so yeah I
think it's it might we might see another
draw here it looks like it could be
Vitali another game that catches my eye
in Group B that I was really looking at
was a shot Chandra's game against Aaron
Group in ski it looks like a shot maybe
a choice here alright let's look at the
game it looks like Aaron Levinsky is
providing us some action right alrighty
so let's see at the moment what do we
have here they just finished move number
forty actually white made move number
forty let you just saw the time jump
right there right it goes so so both of
them just played move number forty so
what do we have here well looks like
white is just a pawn up white also has
this very powerful rock on a5 which
overlooks the AC on the AC spawn and the
g5 pond and
to be honest so if it's white to move
actually it's a king g1 let me refresh
my page real quick looks like both of
them made right so Roxy one was played
black needs to pin this Bishop King f2
and then the rook seat to check now the
problem is that those checks actually
help white because now we're in the
inner end game and we know that in the
endgame we have a very strong piece
which is the King we are taught in the
beginning as beginners that we are
supposed to you know protect the King
keep him in the castle in in home but
now when the Queen's are over the board
most of the pieces of the board then we
begin our King March so yeah so it looks
like the King will probably gonna go to
either g3 or e3 if it will be after me I
would just start marching the the King
just over there and eventually get this
pawn on e6 so for example King to e3 and
to be honest I don't see I don't like
Erin's odds in here yeah it looks like
actually Chandler is doing pretty well
but we don't want to jinx it right right
well you mentioned the Kings in the
endgame in fact in most end games it
seems the Kings are really good at actor
attackers and it's actually necessary if
you leave your King at home trying to
protect them you're gonna get back rank
mated exactly yeah it's it's an
interesting nuance of the game oh yeah
yeah definitely so we are definitely
going to keep an eye on this game
where errand elegantly he has on his
side he has the time advantage and now
115 minutes versus 30 minutes but I
think that the idea for white is pretty
it's pretty obvious here I'm just gonna
move my king and how are you going to
defend this pawn this pawn a6 is gone
that's a goner I mean and then the bite
that is going to have to protected
passed pawns and yeah
so that's that is that does not look
good for for Aaron it looks really good
for Chandra right that's for sure okay
so maybe we can look at some some other
games that's some other games who got
finished we said and we are going to
discuss this game and rhaegar of its
versus if Gainey check Steinberg
let's see what happened in a game d4 c4
e6 by the way pretty good pretty good
comeback for Andre because he lost
yesterday yes he did nice right he was
sitting at the bottom against action
right lost against a chef so he's loan
at the bottom right now but very early
on so again we don't want to jinx it but
he Fox at the wins he's gonna be still
on the top right yes a $64,000 Fischer
prize go a whole thing undefeated yeah
you know we don't by the way but ya know
it's that's superhuman so it looks like
Stalin was a type of a Catalan defense
very popular fan shooting the bishop on
g2
castle 96 so in those kind of positions
as you can see black/white sacrifices
opponent c4 but in return white gets the
the center and many many times it pushes
the pawn to e4 as it did the next move
and well this is what we call a
positional advantage a little a the
positional sacrifice so white has those
beautiful pawns on e4 and d4 black in
return has the pawn on c4 is a pawn up
but here's some some troubles in
developing his pieces I mean this Bishop
on see eight a might find some trouble
to find a spot for himself so let's see
what happened in the game night a5 okay
Bishop to e3 rook to b8 Queen e2 b5 okay
so defending this despondency for so far
so good it looks pretty good for for
black this move this move a six
I wonder if black hoody we just play
here Bishop to b7 so I just wanted to
finish my development and obviously
white cannot take on d5 because it's
going to lose the e4 pawn so if white is
losing the central pawn and that's
that's really pretty good for for black
there's no more advantage for white I'd
like to get gorebyss input on this game
and especially at this point let's let's
hold off on that because I understand we
are gonna have it here shortly and while
we can since our time is very near and
dear and limited to us let's take a look
at another game in the interim let's
look at Malika Cochin versus a victim
Michalowski you can wave ski and catchy
an okay while is growing out of the
board
the King was on a tree
against the king had to run away by the
way we are in move number 28 and look at
the time that Victor has he has less
than two minutes a minute and 50 seconds
so let's let's see what's going on is so
white is has a rook against a bishop and
a pawn but this one is a passed pawn so
material material speaking white
supposed to be better his Queen only
five is very strong the rock on d7 looks
pretty good my guess is that the King
had to escape to a three because of the
check on g2 and now why does not want to
leave his King on a1 that's a pretty
strange position where the king is feel
safer on 80 it is what it is visually a
little bit odd right
the King is before the pawns not behind
the pawns but what to do I mean we have
55 seconds 53 seconds I mean the victim
needs to make mr. maker make like who
did we ever had anybody have a lose on
time I don't think so usually it's
really tough to right in these
situations one thing to keep in mind
these players are only on move 29
they're not gonna get any bonus time for
another 10 moves right moves that extra
half-hour kicks in on both clocks so the
Flex key is he's maybe it's sweating out
a little bit right here
oh yeah definitely so let's see what can
he do what is this thing you know well
probably needs to defend the rope but
were to move the rope so let's try to
move the rope somewhere roof to e1 and
what is the problem
I wonder if black can play this move
rook to f2 and attack the a to pawn
maybe that is what he is calculating
what move the row because rook F 2 is
coming
it's not so easy for for--why to defend
I mean I'll probably have to play
something like rook a1 next so why did
we play rook e1 and then okay one
interesting so let's a flash the
position here what was played in the
game haha and in the game
white played rook to d1 I have a feeling
that white wants to sacrifice the rope
for the bishop just this bishop is just
too strong hospital especially to get
off the pawn so I think that is what
he's thinking about especially when he
doesn't have so much time so what about
this move rook c7 looks promising
yeah I mean that's that's probably a
mating thing to write the rook takes it
to his coming King before and we have a
five that would be pretty nice make
almost a meter White has the second
Queen yes okay exactly but but still
still not good for white yeah yeah I I'm
not sure what maybe we are missing
something else so what else can black do
here but yeah I would I would just play
rook F 2 and the problem is that even if
I take on d3 here he's gonna take on on
a 2 and do the same thing
came before hmm
okay well now it's not emit because can
be five the would we consider this is an
endgame now and the king is really
strong I would say so yeah yeah my daily
game yeah it actually looks like why it
is going to get the upper hand because
it takes that the black King would be
very very weak in this position so I see
some moves
well played let's refresh the port and
many played queen g4
queen g4 was played and the queen is is
attacking the rook here on on d1 so that
that makes some some sense yeah and
again Victor is an enchant time trouble
he needs to figure out how to how to
respond not so easy
so will he take on on d3 or not that is
that is a good question what else can he
do well actually also his rook on d7 is
being attacked attacked so
what can Y do here and
and let's see so what can do I do here
maybe just to take on d3 and how did you
sacrifice maybe we have some kind of an
intermediate check on d8 okay so we are
going to get back to this game but right
now we have an intriguer of it with us
today yes thank you for joining us
congratulations on you win today we were
just discussing you that you will only
played 27 moves but quite impressive
right quite a quick win we've seen some
other players make some draws after 30
moves so 27 moves I assume it came
prepared for the game
partly I was prepared here but then I
mean it was very complicated and I
bluffed a little bit so okay let's go
over the game maybe you can so it was a
Catalan right Indian yeah start as an
Enzo and kind of touch balls so this is
pretty much old theory after d5 and he
decided to go back with the bishop yeah
sure yeah you know fortunately for me
the idea of this opening is like I was
watching a bittersweet lawyers doing
filled DVD and then I I mean it looks so
nice for black sacrificing of the spawns
and then I mean I realized that it's
gonna be one better for white if you're
trying to do this [ __ ] up so I consider
this as just a reversed green filled
right that's the idea with it where they
move up here
idea yeah and also there was like an
inspirational game played by some boys
against you and you from China just a
year ago so yeah and we were following
that game okay good luck interesting
yeah so it looks like you guys both knew
the line yeah
Castle so so now you're basically
sacrifice the poem but you get those
efore pawns and default points pretty
strong and on Knight e5 theory right
through b8 there was one moment here
after b5 rook 81 maybe this book 86 was
not so necessary but they maybe play
just Bishop b7 and yeah probably so if
so because if you take on b5 then yeah
you fall is falling for me yeah yeah so
that's that that's what I was wondering
maybe just needs to keep development
probably you have like 95 or something
95 for my beer when g v g5 you take the
floor if i something interesting to
investigate that definitely the rook is
aligned with the queen yeah something's
gonna happen here okay yeah one might be
like e 5 the standard tag yeah nice okay
so he played a six laid a six and now
you play the 95
g4g for that's what's the idea
very nice taking some more space on the
kingside yeah very nice
okay did you did you look at did you
only think about it on that one he
surprised me actually because he didn't
play names Indian soft and so I forgot a
lot of things here but okay interesting
so g4 Knight to b3 so the nine has to go
to beat it but not doing that much too
much of a trouble for us computer
doesn't like it maybe but yeah I mean
the f4 those good to me yeah because if
it takes then you can always take that
yeah yeah looks pretty good Queeny eight
so so far so far very very solid and
then we saw this rook lift yeah - let's
see what xx yeah so the idea was
probably okay GT right an early age
three and connect five very interesting
and I wrote d8 was play cook h3 you know
so preventing Queen age five year
college fund can hit me and if it tries
to play f6 f6 G of GF & Quincy for at
least
and then the ECX point is also sometimes
okay okay so g6 can rotate six logics
because I felt that I need to start with
five four blagghhhhh because sometimes
let's imagine I'm over go my queen comes
to H fool it's right here would somehow
he would play h5 right and my country
play is an H 5 H 5 and he can't a
compass we can it can take on the Sun
but then we have your Potter's pinned
yeah ok interesting idea
so now you're switching sides with them
they are rocking the Queen yeah yeah
plus maybe I could even triple up in
some variations like brink like rook F
one root of three rook h3 wow this would
be amazing and then Queen to h4 yeah Wow
very nice
but yes I'm thinking that black has a
lot of difference of resources yeah if
net Queen c6 and maybe it was time for
him to start exchanging pieces yeah but
he didn't want to take on G one because
the 91 and Knight goes F 2 and G 4 and
have six it's a it's kind of the it's
kind of a race like who's gonna make you
first no you're the King side and he's
in the Queen side looks like he
succeeded more on the Queen side and
centered on Isaac
yes very very interesting okay so in the
game he played Queen c6 Knight to d5
that was the moment Wow I have to play
95 because other things just don't work
so if you try to play rook F 1 FS
through d3 okay and even in some lines
rook takes history bright idea to take
and then Bishop c5 doesn't work so I
decided to play and yeah the crucial
woman here that I found can be won this
is very important because if Queen f2 if
Queen after that he has going g4 let's
say and
ya can't continue and work for white
because your rock is hanging garokk next
you will take undefined some yeah and
then they will connect ch6 looks very
awkward maybe if you exchange the coins
and I put King g7 okay this move very
creative so he's trying to bring his
ribcage because I mean what else
otherwise how to play coinage for all
right this might yeah obvious approach
testing okay so King Jesus Evans and now
you decide to play Ruby Bishop HD yeah
so if Queen h4 then just rotate yeah and
actually here after a five you should
have played through cage for propitiate
that's right but it's very difficult to
make because giving him back that the
piece has to give up the piece but the
basic concept of difference you know
sometimes you give up your extra
material yeah so he put instead she
takes five yeah and that's a blunder
okay so on so maybe maybe didn't see
maybe he was expecting Bishop takes a
five is the same actually vicious still
wins and college for would be winning
the drive looks like the King was left
along their own yeah and also there's a
big cluster of pieces when the King
cannot escape to check first
yeah
and it was for me very easy to find
because reminds me of the famous game
Alaska against someone you know double
Bishop sacrifice can look similar yeah
so if the King escaped somewhere than
just Bishop six to five and checkmate on
h7 Wow
so very good game I got like you yeah
yeah of course and I mean yo Publio
prepared so and you you risked as well
and yeah so good for you I think it's a
very nice compact right after
yesterday's yeah and that's not such a
good yesterday my opponent played
brilliantly actually very well because
very well prepared and nice how are you
enjoying your time in st. Louis you're
not from st. Louis right I mean it's
always good here yeah welcome so a good
luck thank you for joining us and in
came back for the for the rest of the
games thank you and we are going to go
into a short commercial break question
on Twitter from dem s I should not have
pronounced that that was a bit of a
champion
[Music]
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba 3 is an illegal move
here because white advances for two
squares not one but it still is
something we call hustle and you can do
that but you have to do it instantly you
can't wait for a move I gotta say play
King in seven games e2 and now try
because y'all played four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
the playing during the course of my
steak yeah he told me this is that d5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we finally know who
Lawrence this is not how chess works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of my quality of
life has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
or Paris
or even combination
you could fly all over the world but why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm hi I'm Mike Matheny well you play
chess for fun or want to boost your
child's academic performance come visit
the Chess Club and scholastic center of
st. Louis right here in the chest
capital of the u.s. from a welcoming
diverse environment to a Scholastic
outreach program now in over 100 schools
our Center across from the world chess
Hall of Fame the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
hello chess fans and welcome back to
live round coverage of the second round
for the 2018 spring chess classic I'm
here with a special guest my name is Ben
Simon joined by senior tournament
director and chess scholastic
coordinator Richard at Columbia Point
that's that's a lot of titles there
Richard yes
I'm very proud of the senior tournament
director title that I just achieved yeah
took a very long time so what does that
consist of you just became a senior
tournament director what is that
consistent so the US Chess Federation
has a couple requirements basically they
have a testing requirement which is not
too difficult but you do have to pass
with an 80% so you can fail pretty
easily and then you also have to direct
ten tournaments with about a hundred
players each so it can be easy depending
on where you live but for us often times
we don't get that many players in our
tournament so because of space
restriction so finally got there took
about two and a half years so pretty
long time so you deal with a lot of
scholastic tournaments the kids and we
all know that the kids invent the
craziest chess disputes ever
I suppose this helps your situation well
it's interesting that the test has some
questions on it that relate to computers
playing in chess tournaments or you know
players having a foul odor but
unfortunately there's not Larry
and had a lot of questions about
scholastic tournaments which if I were
recommending I think they should ask
more questions like that because it's
useful actually kids you know they play
games just outside and you know off the
board as well so to be ready to for all
situations in scholastic tournaments of
course and and this year we're looking
forward to on the grand stage the grand
chest tour the very best in the world
playing in their own circuit and you get
points for placing high and you still
get something from place in low and then
at the end there's a small little
tournament for players a knockout and
then the winner is the grand chess Tour
champion scholastics has something
similar here in st. Louis tell us about
the Scholastic Grand Prix so related to
our monthly chess tournaments that we
host for scholastics is the Grand Prix
so players can come and play and
accumulate points towards a similar type
tournament at the end of the season so
you're given basically points for
winning but also just attending in a
tournament so kind of to drive repeat
repeat players to you know consistent
yeah exactly so we found that you know
it's another way for kids to compete and
you know show their love of chess right
Howard what's the feedback like from the
kids and the parents I'm not sure the
kids really know that it's going on but
I don't know that I would if I was
playing I mean I think that that might
be an exaggeration but you know they
really care about their chess game so
that's the most important result the
parents love it because it gives them
something else to track if they're you
know their child's success it's not
really any different from like you might
see like a coach with a little league
baseball game you know the parents are
really into it right and the kids are
like no it's pretty cool yeah the fans
might be more into it yeah so it's
really it's actually a whole lot of work
as well because you have to track you
know if we have last tournament we had
241 players show up so they
get registered in this Grand Prix
whether or not they ever show up again
so as you keep doing that you had more
and more players to track and make sure
you get their points correct and stuff
like that I want to bring up a
tournament that's not I don't think was
a part of the ground Prix but there's
always like crazy awesome stuff
happening here in st. Louis and on the
scholastic level I know that there's a
lot of partnerships that give us
tournaments like the one at the Moto
Museum last week I think it was last
week right right it was so I think it
might have been two weeks ago but
basically we're in the st. Louis Public
Schools here in st. Louis and there's
about 70 total schools but we're in
about 35 and we give chess programming
and chest lessons to students in those
schools and we had our first
district-wide
chess tournament for the seamless public
schools at the Moto Museum which is a
motorcycle museum here in st. Louis near
st. Louis University it's really cool it
is very cool the venue was great it's
kind of interesting because I'm not sure
the kids had enough time to actually
look at the motorcycles but you know so
they just played on the showroom floor
right they just made all the motorcycles
out of there yeah I think I'm not really
sure what the venue was before we showed
up it was it was already had tables but
yeah it was it was really cool actually
the venue would be a great space for
anything but for a chess tournament it's
kind of unique I think well Richard we
know that you're always fighting the
good fight with the chests and schools
here in st. Louis making scholastic
programming a regular thing something
that the schools feel like they really
should have to improve their kids
progress in schools anything else coming
down the pike anything you want to add
um well summer is coming so that's great
for scholastics we're gonna have a whole
bunch of chess camps most of them are
gonna be off-site we're not really sure
quite yet where we're gonna host them
but stay tuned go to st. Louis chess
club org if you want to find out more
very nice
Richard as always thank you for joining
me maybe we'll have you on like every
turn of it or something that'd be great
I love it all right we'll be right back
with more analysis of round 2 the games
are wrapping up here in st. Louis for
the spring chest
classic
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
and just like that we're back here in
st. Louis for the 2018 that spring chess
classic this is live around 2 coverage
I'm Ben Simon and I'm international
master of Italian aimer and during our
interview with Richard W pointer I
understand we did have a result Batali's
oh yes so we had one draw in Section A
let's look at that draw between Geoffrey
Zhang and de leus spirits
yeah it looks it looks pretty equal we
have a rook end games with the bishops
and night to each it looks like white
could of taking well cannot take on c4
because of rook to d1 check so it needs
to probably move his King and that gets
the the a pond after Ruby - yeah so we
have another another draw which probably
keeps kids jelly in the lead as far as I
remember over the one one and a half
right yeah he's leading live with by a
half point one and a half above the
field yeah so so some draws we have only
one decisive game today so far let's
look at some some other games let's see
what's going on
Chandra and grab Minsky we're in an
endgame right there and it looks like
Chandra's doing pretty well against the
national master yeah so as we said white
did get that a six pawn and we are in an
endgame White has two pawns up I do not
know how can like even try to play for a
draw I mean obviously black is trying to
play something that King g6 King f5 and
pawn to g6 but I think that white will
not allow that white plays rook to b8
and now it is Aaron's move now look at
look at Aaron's time though he has an
hour more if only an hour would give you
if you can only exchange an hour for a
few pieces but syrup to be eight has
played and now basically white needs to
start and push his pawns b4 b5 a4 a5 and
I'm not so sure if black has any chance
here again don't want to jinx it but it
looks it looks pretty good for for white
absolutely it does
Shondra definitely in the driver's seat
here another game that's piquing my
interest in the same section by tally is
Amoco Levski and Kashian there's some
moves rapidly coming across the board
and black has formed a battery on that
second rank right so as we said this
this white had to make some tough
decisions let's see where we left it we
left it after Queen - G - we're not in
this position and wipe did play Queen
backed it play Queen g4 forking the
two rooks check King h7 quintic takes on
a seven a half so that is the black
cannot take the rook on d1 because there
will be some kind of a checkmate after
root seven rotate 7 then Queen g7 so
black played roof to f5 with the idea of
rook coming to a5 and forking the Queen
and the king we have before was played
to defend against this threat
look to f2 okay probably the idea would
be something like Bishop to c4 in this
case white once
black wants to take on a two with a
checkmate so let's see how a Victo
defender of the Queen to c7 to protect
the c-4 square we have rope to g2
okay that's it recipe I like this one
because now the rook is defending the g7
pawn and it's freeing up the Queen on g4
because previously they could not remove
the Queen from G's for so she's fitted
or whatever she wants to rope to e5
after he won I'm sorry Queen to h4
attacking the rook and rotates on d3
okay so this is pretty much what we
predicted white what what we'll
sacrifice in the end one of his rocks
for the d3 bishop just one 1007 now he
played Queen f2 okay interesting and
look at that you can take on d3 he can
take the the rook on e one but he
prefers to play Queen after that's a
pretty bold decision the engine was
going crazy for taking on a one by the
way okay so let's see yeah I would I
would look at all those moves Queen
takes you on
so probably the rook needs to go
somewhere let's say the route goes to
back to d7
and now we have Quincy one check we can
start hunting hunting the King down or
maybe black can play this one d5 and
basically trapping the king here and I
don't see how white can defend from the
mate on c1 and then it could be -
checkmate
hmm that is a pretty interesting point
and I think that medic maybe missed this
maybe it was the the miss of his game
but let's see what happens so he played
Queen f2 the threat is a matinee to go
into c4 all right that's a good move and
now it is still black to move if you can
see that actually I think we have a few
other moves that were played yes so
Queen takes you wanna move to d8 Oh
Spade
so if you see here we have one minute
for each player so let's stay tuned
Rudy a the threat is and there's still
just three three moves from time
controls so they're gonna make it but
it's gonna be a uncomfortable yeah I'm
gonna be very close if that would be
black I would maybe try to give a few
checks this is one of the techniques we
have in such in such time pressure just
to repeat repeat some moves and to gain
time on the clock the first check that
comes into mind is Quincy won so wonder
if he just wanna if you're just going to
play this of Quincy one and then Quincy
to check and I think it was actually
played in the game so Quincy one King a
foreign Queen c2 we are at move number
38 so just two more moves
to the time control and the king went to
b5 oh wow and I think we actually
discussed almost this position before
when the King goes to b5 and we said
that that's a pretty strong endgame
that's that's what I call King play yeah
so now it's it's interesting so let's
see we have four points to each side but
it seems to me that if at some point
white will manage to exchange the Queens
then this King on b5 is gonna be the ACE
he's gonna just take swap this upon b6
or vote from the board and you know
defend his response to a queen this
point on e4 although it's a passed pawn
for black and he wants to promote is
gonna be very very easy for Y to stop it
with rook to e8 so yeah so I think that
that white found a safe heaven for his
King on b5 wow what a turn of events
I mean white black was literally mating
white and suddenly he's just sleep
slipped from his hands so let's see what
happened in the game black check again
on g5 again yeah man it had to make a
decision in 30 seconds that's that's
that's very difficult decision so it
tries to check and I wonder if if Victor
is going to take this point b6 or if
he's going to go somewhere else
my guess would be that he is just going
to take on b6 because if I go to a six
for six then black can follow with Queen
a for some more annoying checks so yeah
I wonder if I can just snap this board
off the board
when take King takes on b6
and I think that it was played black
played Queen after check and came to be
seven Wow can you promote the Queen the
planning to promote the Queen the King
I'm sorry I want to check the rulebook
on there I know yes you know maybe if
the King comes to the back rank then he
gets some extra super powers well as you
can see the players have made time
control right so both of the players
made both number 40 and this is when
they get 30 moves 30 minutes extra on
the clock and as you can see always
usually what happens is they usually
stand up just to stretch their feet
wipe that what wipe that sweat of their
brows yeah I mean I mean ten moves in
what like two minutes or something like
that it's pretty exhausting so let's see
what was played so right now it's Malik
here there are no more checks that's it
he he he has exhausted all of his checks
in the position I mean there is a Queen
f7 check but this girl is defended by
the cool bite by the White Queen and
what else can he do let's think about
this well the probable black if he's
trying to play III maybe Y can start
hunting is king 26:28 a king g6 maybe
check on d6 but then maybe the black
king is getting activated so I doubt if
why it wants to do that very interesting
position so how should white play after
e3 probably rook e8 we need to stop this
is criminal obviously
and now black cannot play pawn to eat
too because it's just want to get taken
well here's the thing
suddenly after e3 black can check the
White King on this diagonal he can do it
by playing Queen f3 or queen g2 but
what's the problem in this with this
move queen of three the problem is that
the White has a very strong defense that
allows him to exchange the Queens
playing 24 and again if we get to such
an endgame this truck is going to easily
stop this pawn probably even take it the
White has three passers that's a monster
that's can't deal with that yeah yeah
that's even this we can't even jinx
they're not superstitious to begin with
but yeah but yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see how how the game
continues and I think yeah the Israeli
Misha Levski is doing very well and I
have to tell you a wonderland and
Alexander fear the Brazilian have drawn
ok game so that's yet another draw
that's in Group B group B's looking a
little more dynamic than a today we
might end up with all draws in Group A
let's see I'm looking at Chandra in
group in ski and yeah this this one is
looking looking like a wrap here oh yeah
look look at that what what how did
black allow the white king to come to g5
what happened here so we left here Ruby
it was played Rock City
hey for now g4 oh I don't I don't need
it like that it releases the white king
I think that the correction was somehow
- it's hard to point out what was the
correct move here for for black but I
was thinking about king g6 and somehow
bringing the king to f5 with the ideas
such as taking the pawn on e5 or playing
g4 that that would be an interesting
counter play but instead g4 really is
not a threat because king h4 now that
the rook see - what if he would I wonder
why he he did not want to take enough
take take take rook takes King takes
here
check well even if it serves 19 g4 and
again if I take if I get this despoina
for the game is going to be over but
maybe I can play something like rook 8 3
and then I assume white as a few options
well if I try to play a 5 maybe now this
point if they might become dangerous but
also white can can probably just play
King g4 here and give up here of the
spawn and those two passers will
definitely win the win the game so let's
see what happens in the game itself
Aaron played Roxy - and now ping g5
interesting
now the idea is actually sometimes white
has some ideas to checkmate black with
the rope b7 and coming through king of
six just a simple checkmate with a king
in the rope and then just checking on
the back rank so we have a few moves
playing here let's flash the board
so we have kimchi five
ro G - he makes a full roof 2 F 3 a 5
rook takes of T and it is exits more
weight now while the King will probably
go back to g5 and the question is will
Aaron get some counterplay will have you
have some chance he can take this pawn
on e5
but I wonder if I can just play a-six
and a-seven and a-eight
there's a no way for me to stop at pond
yeah so I thought we and in this
position also Y can take king efore I
mean really those two passers just
unstoppable so for example kingi for
rook eight three lots of options usually
I can just swing my route to be six and
maybe play something like a six and B
five I wonder if I can also play
something like route h8 and just take
this this other part yeah if I will be
white I would just play king g5 I like
this this move King g5 just to keep the
pressure on those pawns [ __ ] if I can
take those two guys or even just one of
them black won't have any option to get
a passed pawn in that case those two
pastors pathetic testers that's pretty
much a win-win situation all right well
I guess we're gonna get back to this
position but it looks like her actually
it's doing pretty good yeah absolutely
he's he's doing great
it's he'd have to really work to lose
this one I just want to let you know I
draw in Group B JJ a lemur on D and
international and pardon me now
Grandmaster priyadarshan canna pan they
have reached a drawn position the game
is over let's see who else is left if we
have any kind of interesting positions
here the game of the day Alexander only
shook is paying as Surya Ganguly as I
said that that one structure if you
remember wife had all the high spots on
the fourth rank so we saw a few
exchanges right now it's looking pretty
equal why it is probably slightly better
just because of his heroic on b7
cutting off of the king but I cannot see
any clear plan fall for white probably
just bring the king to g3 then maybe
pawn to f3 maybe somehow bring at the
king somewhere the problem is that if I
start marching the came to this side
there is always roof to a tree chat and
also I suspect that black is going to
push d5 next move I wonder if we can do
it immediately if t51 takes Knight takes
on d5
looking pretty equal wide kenpo this
night under five that's a beautiful
night under five I gotta say but I'm
gonna put my head in there for
it's a beauty contest between the nights
so yeah it depends because if then this
night takes h6 well my roof is gonna
come here gonna take on on h3 yeah I I
feel like it's gonna until the end of
the draw although they did pass the time
and for the Foley move so they have half
an hour each I think there's this game
is gonna go for a while and what about
bruised own vs. Edward Cuba vs. France
we haven't looked at that game at all I
believe yet you know you've a
interesting match Cuba vs friends let's
see
okay so what do we have here yeah so all
the prayers past more number for the
everybody got the text of time as far as
I can see right now black has a pawn up
but blacks King is tied up on the back
rank because the rook on the a7 is doing
such a good job and as we said it's
pretty much like white is playing with a
piece up because of his King so the King
had come to e4 and created much damage
that's that is what I'm I think that
White's plan is king you for maybe just
to keep the King on d4 I'm not even sure
who I would fulfill here to be playing
black oh oh to be playing white because
black is a corner but those all those
pawns on g5 d 6 a 5 looks like
witnessing witnesses to me and I'm not
sure what is blacks plan maybe maybe
it's time to offer a draw just just play
rook to d2 and maybe just start those
crazy exchanges group to a5 rope here
room to g5 rook here look to b5
and yeah I mean this is this is just not
the king comes out and this should be
should probably end in the draw let's
see if let's see what what did they have
in the opening they had a Sicilian in
the opening g6 by the way this this
system has a few names some some people
call it the hyper accelerated dragon
very very fast dragon and some people
call it the sniper I've never heard the
sniper oh yeah this lightly
so because the bishop comes here very
very fast to g7 so sometimes Bishop can
come to g7 even sacrificing this pawn on
c5 because black and they captured this
pawn on c5 but in the game white black
took immediate e96 and c4 Bishop to g7
attacking the knight Bishop to e3 that
there is very much old theory
this is what we call the Marathi bind
when wiped has those two pawns on e4 and
c4 the advantage for white so sometimes
wife puts the the policy for sometimes
he leaves the opponent on c2 so what is
the difference well in many lines black
tries to get counter play by playing
this move d5 or b5 right a 60 B 5 or
eces d5 now when white puts the pollen
c4 though it's gonna be extremely
difficult for black to - to play one of
those moves so let's see what happened
okay Knight to g4 that's a typical
maneuver Quinta is G for green goes back
to d1 and now II five Wow 'if I've that
is actually a move that I have never
seen before but I'm not another sniper
not a sniper and not a sniper player but
II five looks a little bit of strange
yes black does get this 94 but first of
all II five looks a bit suspicious to
put the pawn here just a fun bit of the
bishop I don't like to you know block up
might make snapple and on g7 but also
black gives away this disability five so
let's see what happened
everyone canceled everyone develop their
pieces Knight to d5
yeah looks like looks like in this game
we have the the battle or between the
Knights which Knight looks better okay
so finally black decides to exchange
this night thing f5 and white also takes
the knight we have a few exchanges here
white white got a pawn up actually so
white has a few ideas but black does
have the initiative of Queen to g4 rook
e1 went to h4 so now black has some
really serious threats on h2 g3 has
played Bishop takes g3 Wow
does that sound yeah yeah because I
cannot take with it with the H bond
because of because of the of the pin and
if I take with the ad with a porn
probably that's what happened again the
rook takes have fun I think that this
was White's blunder I would yeah that's
probably white forgot about the small
Bishop to e3 otherwise you could have
played h3
I'm sorry if G three Bishop takes g3
what's what's the deal why can't take g3
well that that is actually what happened
in the game F things g3 and their roof
takes on f1 Czech rule takes are falling
now the bishop Leefolt oh the bishop Inc
okay right so I think that yeah I think
that Brazil probably miscalculated this
variation let's go back so how could he
have improved action Chandra has just
defeated Arron Korbin ski or i Griffin
ski has called it a day yes so the
result we did expect yeah so action is
leading right right now he is by a full
point in the in the live standings now
we still have one more game going in
Group E mikhalev ski and catch Ian that
game is like we last looked at it pretty
good for me Kalev ski and we have the
two games that look very even in group a
Ganguly ona shook and burrs own Edouard
so the these games will go beyond our
broadcast yeah so Oxford has a lot of to
write he's two for two
yeah he's fired back with with some
theory you know after after the last
event he played here in st. Louis it was
not his best showing and now he's really
he knows what he can do no and if you
talk to him he's a very well-spoken
young man he's always very friendly and
he's very upbeat and he he knows like
look we were talking about went from
1500 to 2500 in five years wow that's
amazing
it is a very interesting story he has to
tell ya so it's good to see AK shot
playing so well to begin this tournament
and he's only 17 leaf I believe
he's only 17 years old and yeah he's
here in st. Louis actually I believe
Akshata is 18 or 19 okay yeah it's tough
to keep you know it's like just
yesterday these kids you know they were
so little no oh yeah yeah it's hard to
keep track yeah yeah
yeah but still you see those youngsters
coming in today and yeah especially you
know st. Louis has lots of good masters
right now probably could something is
connected with the the Chess Club right
I wonder if you make a poll how many
people made enormous here in the
tournaments I mean that'll be a lot of
norms yeah well it that is some
interesting research to be conducted the
problem with norms is you really have to
look at individual tournament results
and calculate for yourself because I
mean other than asking the players there
is not some database you can't go on to
the World Chess Federation fides website
and see how many norms a player has now
this is something I wish that there was
a way you could do right no it makes
things so much easier
these norm Congress tournaments that are
the norm congress the invitational
tournament that we have where players
specifically are there to earn norms I
have no problem asking them individually
you know how many norms do you have
right but it would be good to have some
kind of database you go to and figure it
out for yourself well chess fans we are
wrapping the day up here for our
broadcast we still have several games
left we think we know what will happen
so we're not sure let's take a look at
the standings for a group a and you know
you could say these are provisional
right now because there are two games
left and it looks like they're both very
even Ganguly is playing oh no shook and
bruised own is playing
édouard those games look like they might
be draws which would mean that every
game in this field is drawn today Vitali
I know all right
like I say fight friendship wins and
it's these are really strong players and
the the more strong players you get
together the more draws you're gonna
have that's just the nature of the beat
right I mean if they play perfectly if
you play chess perfectly probably it's
supposed to be a job yeah very
interesting so we're gonna have two
players at the top
still Jeffrey and allyship with a point
and a half yes that would be that would
be what we're looking at and as far as
group B goes we can look at the
standings for Group B we have one game
left in that section Michalowski
is taking on cocky on and like we said
moments ago
Oxshott Chandra going a perfect two for
two so far in the tournament defeating
Aaron gritsky
so you know I'm sure that's gonna see if
you can extend this lead what's your
take so far on this field yeah so it
looks like action is it's at the top of
his game and it looks like if Victor
makovski will win that game he's gonna
be on second place with a point and a
half and then we have a few people with
a point and then half a point I think
after this round
everybody's gonna be warmed up I mean
there is nobody with zero and
everybody's is fighting for win a very
very exciting way exciting to see that
right yeah it's kind of tough sometimes
you you get to the third round or even
after two rounds and someone's still is
dead zero just the big old blue Saget's
yeah it's good for drama but their
morale gets so low you know it really
this is still anyone's tournament here
right exactly especially like we've seen
in the first round with Aaron Levinsky
if he can draw one delaying then
anything can happen anything and Arron
Korbin ski the replacement player for
Grandmaster Tarzan who is unable to play
in this tournament that's a big story
there you know as someone's this is that
effect can that affect you coming into a
tournament that late notice I know this
isn't like boxing but still mentally
does that affect you at all yeah well we
haven't
advantage in a disadvantage with I guess
it's the preparation well for me if I
would be coming is if I would be airing
herb in ski well I wasn't prepared but
so so maybe I can just play whatever I
want to on the other hand other people
will not prepare for me works both ways
yeah well just fans I think that's gonna
do it for our broadcast today we
encourage you to keep on following the
games at us chess champs calm and
remember each day except for the last
two at 1:00 p.m. Central Time the games
start the rounds will begin there is one
round per day this was the second round
tomorrow was the third starts at 1:00
p.m. and we will be on the air at 3:30
p.m. Central for an abbreviated
commentary session so this show was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tammy Hyde is our
technical adviser Jonathan Krantz was
bringing us interviews Isaac Krantz is
on graphics and sound our technical
director is danny Machuca I'm Ben Simon
and I am international master of Italian
aimer
and until tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. this is
us signing out and saying so long from
the show-me-state thank you
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you